i
[Música]
el reino unido está formalmente por
fuera de la unión europea que lo
considera desde anoche un tercer país
para todos los efectos a partir de hoy
empieza a regir el acuerdo comercial
post exit aprobado a última hora por
ambas partes la incertidumbre sobre cómo
será la nueva relación marca el inicio
del nuevo año en el continente tenemos
reporte desde londres y berlín
la humanidad recibe el 2021 en medio de
la crisis ocasionada por el cob y 19 y
toda clase de restricciones implantadas
por los gobiernos para contenerlo las
aglomeraciones tradicionales fueron las
grandes ausentes dando paso a
cuarentenas toques de queda
celebraciones a distancia en la mayoría
de los países
y con más de 83 millones quinientos mil
casos confirmados por kobe 19 y más de
un millón 800 mil muertos el mundo
inicia 2021 con un repunte generalizado
de contagios sin embargo las vacunas que
han sido aprobadas en varios países
representan una luz de esperanza y
avanzan en distinto ritmo las campañas
para inocular a los ciudadanos en varios
países
bienvenidos a una nueva mañana de
información de américa latina y del
mundo aquí en tras 24 mi nombre es
liliana valencia iniciamos en europa
porque a partir de hoy deja de ser parte
de la unión europea el reino unido- y
entra a regir el nuevo acuerdo comercial
que materializa la ruptura entre ambas
partes el en unido cambió su estatus
comercial en el continente a retirarse
del mercado único y la unión aduanera
del bloque ampliamos esta información
con nuestra corresponsal en londres
louis ha pulido luisa cuéntenos con
deseándole también un el nuevo año muy
próspero luisa le pregunto cómo se vive
en las primeras horas de el reino unido
fuera de la unión europea porque se
habla de una incertidumbre hacia el
futuro
feliz año para todos a esta hora se
reporta anormalidad en el puerto de
dover en el reino unido- y también en
cali en francia el ingreso a europa han
transitado pocos camiones hasta este
momento quienes ingresen a francia deben
presentar una prueba negativa del
coronavirus pero lo cierto y la gran
prueba de fuego de cómo será toda esta
nueva logística será a partir del lunes
4 de enero que será el gran día cuando
los conductores tendrán que presentar
documentación hay incertidumbre porque
hay muchos retos para el primero el
primer ministro el primero de ellos es
mantener el reino unido por un lado de
escocia quiere independizarse y por el
otro
irlanda del norte se mantiene en el
mercado común de la unión europea y
además debe demostrarles a quienes
votaron por el bec sido en el 2016 que
este país tendrá riqueza económica tal y
como él lo ha prometido luisa español
donde lograron un principio de acuerdo
para evitar una frontera dura en
gibraltar cuál es la importancia de este
anuncio para la nueva relación comercial
entre las partes
es fundamental porque habrá libre
circulación de ciudadanos gibraltar un
territorio en altamar británico se unirá
al estado schengen además habrá un
régimen aduanero para mercancías y
transporte los detalles serán objetos de
una negociación posterior entre londres
y bruselas quedarse rápidamente además
de otras negociaciones como los
servicios financieros el intercambio de
datos y la economía digital gracias
luisa por la información y entre tanto
el sector empresarial en alemania
asegura que si bien hay incertidumbre
también se siente un alivio al haber
logrado un acuerdo que pudo evitar el
caos de un break sheet duro desde berlín
hablamos previamente con nuestro
corresponsal es todo más sparrow
reino unido es uno de los principales
socios comerciales de alemania y en
particular un destino muy importante
para las exportaciones de este país de
hecho según un estudio publicado el año
pasado unos 750 mil empleos aquí en
alemania dependen de las exportaciones
al reino unido- y las empresas alemanas
tienen unas 2500 sucursales en reino
unido- y de ahí que el acuerdo logrado
de la unión europea y reino unido- haya
sido recibido por líderes empresariales
aquí en alemania con cierto alivio mejor
un acuerdo que ningún acuerdo puede
resumirse las diferentes opiniones sobre
ese acuerdo logrado lo que explica
también el miedo que tenían muchos en el
sector a un posible cambio de año
caótico oa incertidumbre también a largo
plazo a pesar del acuerdo también se
nota cierta preocupación en el sector no
solamente por la burocracia añadida a
corto plazo por los nuevos formalismos
por esa etapa de reacomodo para muchas
empresas
sino también por lo que escribió la
cámara de comercio británico alemana que
aseguró que la economía en este país
debe prepararse para cambios profundos a
pesar del acuerdo logrado cambiamos de
información porque la humanidad recibió
el año nuevo en medio de celebraciones
atípicas marcadas por las medidas para
contener el coi 19 las acostumbradas
multitudes en las principales ciudades
del mundo fueron las grandes ausentes en
cambio hubo toques de queda de
celebraciones con distancia social demos
un repaso por el mundo en asia los
fuegos artificiales iluminaron el cielo
de ciudades como shangai taipei banco y
bombay en egipto los juegos pirotécnicos
le dieron la bienvenida al 2021 en
europa la torre eiffel de parís no contó
con sus acostumbrados visitantes
mientras que en madrid españa los
ciudadanos celebraron desde estos
balcones y ventanas el big ben en
londres volvió a marcar el fin del año
después de tres años de reparación times
square en nueva york estuvo desierto al
contrario de lo que se veía en años
anteriores en méxico la plaza del zócalo
recibió sola el año
y en brasil hubo fuegos artificiales y
en las playas de copacabana no se vieron
las multitudes acostumbradas mientras
tanto trabajadores de la salud hicieron
un minuto de silencio por los miles de
personas muertas que ha dejado el coi de
despedidas al 2020 marcadas por el
impacto de la pandemia de oriente a
occidente líderes mundiales se
despidieron de un año determinado por el
hobbit 19 el presidente chino se mostró
orgulloso de los esfuerzos de su país
por hacerle frente carling ar link 2020
fue un año extraordinario frente al
brote repentino de la pandemia del nuevo
coronavirus colocamos a las personas ya
sus vidas en la máxima prioridad y
logramos el gran amor de la humanidad
con solidaridad y perseverancia
escribimos la epopeya de nuestra lucha
contra la epidemia
el mandatario estadounidense elogió sus
esfuerzos para encontrar una vacuna
gracias a la operación works speed
desarrollamos una vacuna en sólo nueve
meses y ya comenzamos un programa de
vacunación a nivel nacional y estamos
enviando la vacuna a todo el mundo
el presidente ruso vladimir putin llamó
a la unión para superar la segunda ola
de contagios que afronta su país en los
tiempos difíciles pasan siempre pasan y
las cosas más importantes permanecen con
nosotros lo que nos hace nobles y
fuertes y si el amor el entendimiento
mutuo la confianza y el apoyo entonces
me gustaría pedir un deseo a que las
dificultades del año saliente pronto
quedarán en el olvido y todo lo ganado
quedará para siempre uno en su último
discurso en 15 años la canciller alemana
quiso recordar a las víctimas que dejó
la pandemia escandón solo puedo imaginar
lo amargo que se debe sentir por
aquellos de seres amados que están de
luto y los fallecidos por el coronavirus
y aquellos que tienen que luchar contra
las repercusiones de una enfermedad
cuando el virus es disputado por algunos
individuos y por su parte el presidente
francés dijo que los meses venideros
serán duros donde mi infancia fue que en
2021 pase lo que pase podremos afrontar
la crisis sanitaria económica social
terrorista y climática que no desaparece
en el primero de enero
los primeros meses del año serán
difíciles y al menos hasta la primavera
la epidemia pensará mucho sobre la vida
en nuestro país
y como muchos otros líderes macrocentro
sus esperanzas en las campañas de
vacunación que se desarrollarán en 2021
entre tanto los contagios porque hoy 19
siguen en aumento a nivel mundial en la
cifra ya sobrepasa los 83 millones y
medio de contagios acumulados mientras
que las muertes superan el millón 800
mil las esperanzas de la humanidad están
puestas en las diferentes vacunas que
han sido aprobadas en varios países
algunos de ellos iniciaron en diciembre
campañas de vacunación mientras las
farmacéuticas buscan nuevas aprobaciones
de emergencia a los cinco continentes la
vm se sostuvo que 2020 deja lecciones
aprendidas
twenty twenty one de cara al 2021
tenemos la decisión sin g pero profunda
que tomar ignoramos las elecciones del
2020 y permitimos que prevalezca el
enfoque partidista insular las teorías
de conspiración los ataques a la ciencia
dando lugar a sufrimientos innecesarios
para la salud de las personas la
sociedad en general o caminamos juntos
los últimos kilómetros de esta crisis
ayudándonos unos a otros en el camino
desde compartir vacunas de manera justa
hasta ofrecer consejos precisos
compasión y atención a todos los que los
necesiten como una familia global la
elección es fácil hay luz al final del
túnel on the way así finalizamos les
deseamos un feliz año nuevo y los
invitamos a continuar con más en
france24 punto como nos vemos más
adelante
[Música]